okay welcome to this video playing a
teammate of mine does he have his name
in public I guess he has right yeah the
national master too must tell a teammate
of mine so what's not the most exciting
opening here and I but I could I played
that a little bit too quickly that g6
stuff I plays very solid sound style and
it's difficult to get something exciting
going I'll try probably will play some
III stuff III d for now no okay if he
allows h4 I'm going for that it takes
with the f porn
okay getting out of that diagonal movie
yeah not sure how to play this now it's
a very weird unconventional position
sometimes taking on c3 comes into
consideration doubling the pawns here
for example you know so what about this
now I did this to make this Bishop look
a bit weird yeah okay that makes lots of
sense try to activate the bishop I have
things like hmm even the f6 as a move it
looks a bit dodgy to be honest but I
think I'll do that anyway try to limit
White's bishops if I get night h6 f 7 25
I'm almost winning strategically but
won't be so easy to accomplish
very very very complicated unclear
position hmm this is surprising I want
to play that move anyway I'm I were
looking some tech to god no that move
was on my agenda anyway might even be
able to go via g 4g 435 lat it's even
nicer than F 725 I wonder if you should
just take on the on c5 open up a file at
least even though it's not quite clear
what is doing with it
I don't get it but I what is he doing
here I'm getting going to e5 know the
tempo
like this good though okay you may be
able to take and takes you five this is
something that I should take into
account Jackie I can also just take him
check on age five is not a big problem
or no problem at all i can go fa to g7
that's completely okay the thing is at
the end the c-4 podium will be almost
impossible to defend at least i don't
see how he defends it I'm even happy to
trade Bishop g4 because that c4 point
will fall so well known mutti from the
limbs oh I'll just trade this it's as
bad bishop I know but I will win c4 it's
got no way to cover it we cannot
challenge my e5 Knight with this Bishop
at all to do pods on g5 and c5 white
resistless trip takes takes Queen takes
and then Knight f3 threatens and he
loses all his pawns at where I think he
should probably do something against
bishops III that was a pretty pretty
awful structure and I'm not sure not
sure how to give white color to play
there
before tix I don't like that position
already to be honest k rook c8 III yeah
III I don't like I don't like that move
I think after this I should be in really
good shape 6 yeah and he has to get some
kind of counter play now something
drastic the engine suggests takes takes
five yeah it should be something like
that something brutal to get to get the
pieces into the game this is the engine
line with the slight edge to black which
is always weird because the whole
position is kind of exploding jump
nobody i knows but this is just good for
black i mean there's no doubt down yeah
I again best is to sacrifice something
with e5 this is the the engine line and
black again it's only slightly bad habit
but yeah he's just lost know if I this
is dropping and check yeah but should be
for also was a good move check this is a
simple and good if he checks me I just
move the King over here I'm threatening
g4 you're trapping that hoops trapping
that bishop so white white is falling
apart here you resigned the outtakes tix
I can also take with the night but this
is just very simple this is when because
he has absolutely no way now to prevent
material losses no I can
and all the time night will come to you
5 and this will drop and this is also
week so he will drop all his pawns okay
well thanks for watching